our Steve sis Lacan CCSD superintendent
dr. hey-zeus Jarrah are in a war of
words over a bill in the legislature
special session it would have allowed
CCSD to suite money from individual
schools and use that for the larger CCSD
budget Jarrah and state leaders are
blaming each other for the idea but it's
not the first time these two have butted
heads over education funding the
i-team's Vanessa Murphy has their
history of peering governor steve
silicon superintendent dr. hey Seuss
Jarrah disagree over whether the Clark
County School District as a whole should
be able to take funding from individual
schools even if that funding was
specifically meant to go to that school
and that's the theme between them
feuding over funding governor sis elect
made teacher raises a key part of his
plan when he was running for governor
during the 2019 legislature the pair
sparred over funding and whether
teachers would get raises
so bottom line by signee dye the money
that you're committing to those raises
will be there when that budget final
budget bills are signed that money is
going to be there for the raisins sisal
ACK and leaders passed several bills
they said would give CCSD the money for
those promised raises then after the
legislative session was over Jarrah said
they did not have the money for those
raises in the budget after all we're
looking at between 11 and 15 million
dollars per year more that's needed last
August
sisal ACK and legislative leaders
accused two CCSD of messing up its
budget and said they created the mess
and now it was up to them to fix it now
we come to find out that CCSD did not
budget for the contractually obligated
professional development payments and
failed to include those requests during
the legislative session a deal was
eventually reached for those raises and
a teacher strike was averted but that
was just the latest instance of the
governor and legislative leaders
accusing superintendent Chara of not
doing his job well Jarrah has
continually asked for more money in the
budget and accused state leaders of not
properly funding education in
Vanessa Murphy 8 news now